there is a stunning new poll from yougov
which finds that 66 of americans i'm
sorry of republicans
in the southern united states want to
secede from the united states and become
their own country this was a joint poll
between yougov and brightline watch and
they did some interesting things
one of the things that the poll does is
it breaks down the country by regions
so you've got like the pacific region
which is california washington oregon
hawaii
and alaska you've got all these the
northeast et cetera
and what they did was they reported
people's interest in separating
out as a country not at the state level
but as a region if your region could
become its own country
would you want to secede from the united
states
and they asked people this on the basis
of party affiliation so
let's look at some examples here in the
northeast
region as an example which includes
maine new hampshire vermont
new york pennsylvania massachusetts
connecticut rhode island you know a
couple of
maryland delaware they said okay would
you want to be your own
country and secede from the united
states and for example
39 of democrats said yes we do we would
like to be our own region
35 percent of independents and only 26
percent of republicans said i would like
the northeast to be
our own region the largest level of
support in this poll across all regions
and political identifications
is southern republicans if you look at
the southern region
that includes texas florida and a bunch
of other states
66 percent of republicans said yeah
i want to secede i would like our region
the southern region to be its own
country now the absolute most ironic
thing about this
is that the southern region would be
completely unsustainable economically
some of the states that are the biggest
takers
rather than givers when it comes to
federal money
would be in that southern region so said
a different way
some of the states that are the most
dependent
on money that comes from other states
through the federal government are
mississippi
kentucky south carolina louisiana
alabama tennessee arkansas and oklahoma
they're all
in what we would be this southern region
of the united states
texas and florida are kind of in the
middle they're not terrible they're not
great in terms of paying in versus
getting out
so the point here is the group that most
wants to secede from the united states
southern republicans
and make their own country out of their
region
are the ones who states are the least
economically able to do that
and the most dependent on blue states to
subsidize them this isn't new
we've covered this we've done stories
about this before about this contrast
before
it's been true for a very long time now
consider the reality versus perception
their perception is things are really
bad being part of the united states
why because of democrats and liberals
and progressives
like joe biden's communism and his
socialism
and the marxist democrats woke culture
is ruining us
cancel cultural culture is ruining us
men in girls
sports as they love to say it's ruining
the country
and we'd be better off if we separated
and did our own thing that's the
perception that many of them have
the reality is none of that stuff is
actually going on
there are almost no socialists in the
democratic party and however bad things
are in your state
in terms of education and they're very
bad in a lot of these states
however bad things are in your state in
terms of access to healthcare
infrastructure
it would be even worse if you lost the
subsidies you get from blue states
through the federal government
blue states that are paying in much more
than they get out
and making your education system be
slightly less terrible
making your health care system be
slightly less terrible
making your infrastructure slightly less
terrible it couldn't possibly be more
backwards and they have the idea these
southern republicans
if we separated and did our own thing we
would be much better off
but again in a sense just like i don't
take joy
in the anti-vaccine nurse that just died
of covid because i see her as a victim
of disinformation
it's very similar for lots of these
people who wrongly blame their problems
on imaginary issues rather than the real
failures of their almost exclusively
republican
state and local level elected officials
they are also the victims of
disinformation they are persistently
victims by the way also
of a terrible education system in their
states they can't even follow simple
logic like oh
pandemic okay mask for now and then
vaccine once we can get it
they can't even follow that so they are
also victims to some degree now we'll
have a voicemail about this with a
different perspective a little bit later
on
last thing on this it shouldn't come as
a shock
that the group that most glorifies the
side of the confederacy during the civil
war
is the one that most wants to secede
from the union that's actually
consistent
that's not surprising and so it
shouldn't come as a shock to us
we're going to have more coverage of
this poll on our instagram so make sure
you're following us there at david
pakman show
we'll take a quick break and we will get
to the decidedly
overtly anti-vaxxed shift among many
prominent republicans that took place
over this past weekend